I don't know how to ask this, but, you know,
Joe Rogan me had a,
had a sense about you similar to like, uh,
Fedor mm-hmm <affirmative> that you are potentially one of the greatest ever.
Yeah.
Does it hurt that you're not in the discussion now of being in the top 10?
Uh, of all time.
I didn't prove it. I don't deserve it.
You had a, I mean.
But I didn't, I didn't prove it. I mean, and so it's like, uh, had I had,
I somehow gotten to convince Dana white,
we go and convince him in 2013 to make me an offer and I didn't even need a good
offer. I needed any offer. Had I gotten the offer then maybe the outcomes.
Right. But given I would never expect anyone think of me that way.
I didn't prove it. I, I know, I know what I was and I'm good with that.
And yeah. Other people never got to see that.
Do you think, well, you don't know, you can't know fully. Right.
Do you think if you, uh, went to the USFC at that time,
instead of one championship, I think it had a lot of success.
Yeah. They, I mean, there's obviously certain guys,
there's a lot of guys I've trained with that.
I had a lot of really good results against, and, um, obviously who was,
uh.
Walter wait at.
That Tyron was a champion for a long time there.
So I was around Tyron was a champion. Anthony was a champion at lightweight.
I was, you know, same gym as him. And we had a lot of people coming through.
Yeah, I.
Did you face time?
Would I have fought him? I don't think so. I mean,
so he was still the champion when I came into DFC and we said, no,
we're not gonna fight.
All right. <laugh>.
Hey. So he, he can't change history, right? So once something happens,
you gotta accept for what it is and move forward. And,
and obviously hope you can continue to keep accomplishing great things.
Which for me, obviously my athletic career is over.
So now it's gonna be through my wrestling academies and you know,
who knows what else I get, get into.